alors les petits voyous voulaient qu'on
a vu à la télé au nom giscard mitterrand
le pape oui mais ils ont des tubes
bah ouais montgiscard ça commence
toujours par bonsoir madame bonsoir
mademoiselle
bonsoir monsieur je suis venu comme à
chaque rendez vous télévisé vous
rassurer vous rassurer sur le franc qui
est fort qui est stable qui est tenace
le franc qui ne cesse de grimper
je parlais du franc suisse évidemment le
tronçon cadre qu'elle a laissé c'est un
petit peu différent je voudrais vous
parle également de l'armée il ya de plus
en plus de femmes dans l'armée
quelle femme ne femme épatante je les
passe en revue de temps j'entends et au
moins me rassure je me dis avec elle
la france est inviolable au l'un dans
l'autre économiquement parlant
la france arrive maintenant on peut le
dire nettement avant le groenland des
mitterrand le dernier 33 toi tu aimais
bien c'est vrai ouais je dirais que
française pensait je remercie la france
les électeurs qui sont de plus en plus
nombreux
c'est vrai que de plus en plus de
françaises et de français en france
grâce à michel debré qui avait dit à un
moment à l'assemblée nationale il faut
que les françaises et les français les
phases des enfants sur une grande
échelle
patatras et feuilla il ya en france un
avion étonnant de le concorde
c'est le seul avion qu'on nous a pas
pris d'assaut les autres avions les
détourner le nom entre nous le
retournement je ressens très étonnant il
ya autre chose que j'ai pas bien compris
c'est le départ
bic jacques chirac manquer je n'aimais
pas jacques chirac pour que je ne rompt
pas puisque vrillé vous mets mes bien
chers frères en ce troisième dimanche
après la pentecôte je pense que les
seigneurs voir qu'est ce que je raconte
l'allemand excusez moi je suis
complètement mobile et par la main
tendue aux catholiques par monseigneur
marché d'un j'ai peur qu'il ait commis
là un pc mortels mais alors que le pape
dia pape tu as parlé de monseigneur
lefebvre ici et à l'eau je suis les
écrans oui mais là il me l'a dit ça va
mieux avec le pape
oui c'est parce que je n'aime pas ce
terme et en latin oui quand on sait
comment ça c'est le pape c'est
obligatoire c'est chouette le point
tuyaux pour dire cela il me reste pas de
nemo pour acheter tombés d'accord passé
avec mangane toujours en patois bien